oh my banana is a relatively new
designer did a really interesting
presentation today in Milan he was a
stage show that was set right after a
war was ended and it was a bunch of men
in a barracks everything from a guy
taking a shower completely naked someone
getting a tattoo and in the collection
there was a bunch of really wonderful
military pieces however a lot of these
pieces can be mixed in with regular
items I loved a quilted white sweat suit
I was really into the quilting it gave
it a really soft or touch to a lot of
the more harder military pieces in the
show I loved all the epaulette detail on
a lot of the shirting and also the
jackets my other favorite thing was that
there was this amazing wool trench but
it had nylon sleeves it was a kind of an
interesting new version of a your
traditional wool jacket a lot of the
pants were all cargo pants which I love
there was a fantastic great turtle neck
ribbed sweater that you know on its own
with a pair of pants and a scarf you're
good to go for the winter please follow
me on twitter at details mat and for a
more video throughout the week check out
details calm